[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but let's welcome in
ben volen from the boston globe senior
nfl
writer hello ben uh thanks for taking
time to talk to us here today
i read your story about uh the rule
changes so
just right off the bat here what do you
think the the rule changes
that should get us most excited for this
coming season doesn't seem like anything
major
but what would you say no they really
didn't try to do anything major
especially in a covered year they didn't
want to
you know rock the boat too much but i
the most interesting thing is adding
these responsibilities to the instant
replay judge and they're
they're towing a line very very
carefully here uh you can tell it
it's like a half measure to appease the
coaches who want
less pressure on them to have to
challenge and the coaches just want the
calls to be made right
and there's a lot of people in
management in the competition committee
the ownership level
who aren't very comfortable with the
idea of the instant replay official
having
sway you know on officiating and
throwing a flag from the booth
and let's slow everything down to the
nanosecond and frame by frame to see if
there should have been
an offensive holding call so this is
kind of like a half measure
that i think some people inside the nfl
are viewing a little skeptically because
it is
taking them to another threshold that
they don't usually like they did that
for
a year when they allowed instant replay
to be reviewed and they hated it and
they got rid of it
so um this is kind of a measure to make
the coaches happy
john harbaugh from the ravens and the
the coaches subcommittee
were the ones who really pushed this
rule and so they're they're making them
happy but
they're also kind of towing the line and
i think there are a lot of people
skeptical of allowing the replay
official to have too much influence
is it almost to prevent the disasters
like the big egregious missed call
um just the the big pla they don't want
because i almost feel like i've seen
uh officials over the past couple of
years and i don't know how much
communication is between new york and on
the field but
you know dressed as officials they come
out with the earpiece in it seems like
there is some communication already
going on but is this going a little bit
further ben
no question it's going a lot further and
i think uh the the thing that rich mckay
who's the chairman of the competition
committee he's the falcons president
what he said yesterday
is they're only going to allow the
replay judge to
view objective things but did a guy step
on the line
was the ball over the goal line things
that you would think would be objective
although anyone who's watched football
know there's a lot of gray area
in a lot of that stuff interestingly
this proposal would not
fix the saints uh defensive pass
interference call for the nfc
championship a few years ago because
that's a that's a judgment call that's a
penalty this is only for very
objective things did the guy step on the
sideline did he complete the catch that
the ball hit the ground
so they're they're trying to finesse it
and we'll see how it works this year but
um i think certainly this is something
to appease the coaches
clearly they don't want to have to
challenge anymore they want the decision
taken away from them
uh so i think the nfl you know in a best
case scenario this helps
get the calls right but it doesn't take
away from the powers of the officials on
the field but
we'll see how it works you know in
reality of the other rules ben what was
most interesting to you
i mean they're all kind of boilerplate
stuff i mean the the jersey thing is
very interesting they've opened up the
single digit uniforms to linebackers and
and wide receivers and everyone's going
to be fighting for number one and number
two and
you know their old college uniforms but
what i found so fascinating about this i
didn't know this rule existed until
this rule got approved yesterday but if
you're a player and you change your
jersey number for next year
you have to buy all your excess jerseys
that are hanging around the warehouses
for the nfl shop you have to buy out the
jerseys
but if you say i'm gonna change my
uniform in two years from now
that gives the nfl enough time to still
sell your jersey for next year so
there's a big financial component to
this and guys have to decide is it worth
changing their jersey if they have to
spring for 4 000 you know jerseys of
their old number so not only do you have
to decide if you want to change your
number ben
you have to call around to warehouses
throughout the world
how many do you have how many do you
have of my jersey how much you selling
them for
that's a lot of work for these players
okay you just bought three thousand of
your own jerseys and you're gonna and
you change the numbers so what are you
gonna do with them it's
it's a fascinating dilemma um is there a
rule ben
that was not approved uh that you
expected to get
approved or maybe it's been tabled for
uh for years to come
the only thing that surprised me frankly
was that they did approve this rule that
gave the expanded
um responsibilities to the replay judge
i actually didn't think the nfl was
going to move that far
they had a bunch of fun proposals and
basically all the fun ones got voted
down and i i think i did see that coming
just because the nfl like a lot of these
owners they don't do
change lightly and you know instituting
fourth and 15
as an alternative for the onsite kick
sounds great i love it it'd be a lot of
fun
you know it might make the nfl look a
little arena footballish so i think the
enemy
the owners are always kind of wary of
that the sky judge
as i said before the nfl does not really
want to take that step if they don't
have to and said
they created a half measure you know the
bills had an interesting proposal about
the timeline for when you can hire
coaches they
they think it's a distraction for their
coaches who are in a playoff run to be
interviewing for jobs and
maybe they're at it you're at a
disadvantage if you make it all the way
to the super bowl and the hiring team
just wants to move on
with the nfl table and all that stuff so
we've seen it the last two years there
there have been fewer proposals and the
nfl has
accepted fewer proposals just with covey
they're not trying to rock the boat
they're trying to keep things as normal
as possible
hey ben if you'd asked me a couple of
years ago i would have said the onside
kick is gone it's gonna be gone within
five years too dangerous player safety
now it almost seems like they're trying
to make it work
and i i wouldn't bet against it sticking
around for years to come am i wrong in
that ben
no and and you know that's another area
where they
approved of a half measure you know
fourth and 15 would have would have
taken a blow torch to the onside kick
instead they're like let's see if we can
bring the play back you know they change
the
the kickoff rule so much because of
health and safety
that it rendered the onsite kick
completely you know impossible to
recover i think
the numbers i saw were that four of 67
on-site kicks last year
were recovered that's like five percent
you need more than that you need the
play to be competitive again
so they instituted this half measure
where they're limiting the number of
players the defense can have in the box
you can now only have nine players in
the box
the offense can only have five on either
side so
you know maybe that that maybe that
measure will will
help improve the odds of the onside kick
it's just a one year thing
uh the fourth and fifth team will always
be around and if they just can't get the
onside kick
you know back to a competitive play then
i think you know then they'll seriously
look at fourth and fifteen but they
don't want to just take that
major step they want to see if they can
fix the play first ben i'm going to give
you a chance to be
wrong what do you think bill belichick
and the patriots do
on draft night well that's an area of
specialty
especially being wrong about the
patriots in the draft is my specialty
look i think the the play is for the
quarterback is definitely there
i don't think there are as many teams in
front of them that want you know the
final two quarterbacks whoever they
may end up being whether it's lance
fields maybe
matt jones but i i think a lot of teams
would like to trade out of their picks
and i think the patriots really have to
be more worried about the teams behind
them
trading up in front of them for a
quarterback like a washington or a
pittsburgh or new orleans
then you know atlanta philly carolina i
just don't see these teams being in it
right now so of course
you know the play is there for the
patriots to go get trey lance and
i think that'd be terrific sit him
beside kim uh newton for a year
maybe even find a role for trey lance
you know while
maybe do the two quarterback thing like
the saints did with taysom hill and drew
brees
you know so i would like the patriots to
make a bold move
um to get one of these quarterbacks and
i think the opportunities there
that said this is the patriots they'll
probably take a guard from rutgers you
know
and i do like the idea too if maybe they
take a real player at 15
but they can always trade up into the
back end of the first round go get
number 31
and go get kellen monde or kyle trask or
whoever they like there so
to me it's a major disappointment if the
patriots don't come out of the first two
days of the draft the first three rounds
if they don't have a quarterback
because clearly they just don't have the
answer on their roster and they can't
keep doing this where they're just
kind of hoping and praying that a
quarterback falls in their lap they need
to be bold
and go do something about it if you
could pull the fans right now who do you
think they would pick to be their
quarterback
next year and maybe into the future cam
newton
uh rookie quarterback or trade
back for jimmy g jimmy garoppolo
yeah jimmy g is the guy that i think
fans realistically won as the answer
and i just don't think it's gonna happen
this year i just get the sense
the niners feel they have a championship
caliber roster and they're not ready to
turn that team over to some rookie
especially coming off a coveted year in
a
you know a strange pre-draft process so
i think they're serious about keeping
garoppolo
i think he'll be he hope i do think
he'll be in play next offseason but i
just don't
see it right now the patriots fans are
not into cam newton there's been a lot
of
unrest from the fans like this is the
best that you guys could do again after
the season that cam just had
um so we'll we'll see but clearly rookie
you know
the fans are ready for the team to
invest in a rookie i don't get the sense
that they necessarily want fields over
lance or anything of that nature i keep
hearing that lance would be a tremendous
fit for the patriots offense
again he's a guy who needs to sit so
that's you know no pressure situation
with the patriots cam can play for this
year and then and trey lance could sit
but the fans overwhelmingly want this
team to
go big go bold uh and invest in a
quarterback
well ben i'm rooting for you i don't
want you to be wrong i want you to be
right you're right about a whole lot ben
vollen
senior nfl writer for the boston globe a
lot of great insights on the rule
changes in the nfl and what the patriots
may or may not do
thanks ben all right thanks a lot